je
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
guillaume à vigo et ceis politologue
votre dernier ouvrage guillaume bigot
populo phobie paru aux éditions plon
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à vos
côté edouard de lamaze avocat au barreau
de paris bonsoir edouard de lamaze merci
d'être avec nous alors pas de procès
donc pour la famille de sarah halimi le
meurtrier est déclarée irresponsable
cette décision stupéfiante
on va dire sans mauvais jeux mots
comment la cades est fier yevou
guillaume bigot
tout est un tout raté dont sept dans
cette affaire c'est à dire que quand on
regarde un peu de presse qui sait ce qui
s'est passé l'instruction était déjà un
peu les évènements ou même de la police
est arrivée sur place a attendu vingt
minutes
le calvaire de cette pauvre madame
halimi a duré assez longtemps
ils ne sont pas intervenu parce qu'il
pensait qu'elle avait d'ailleurs
terroriste ensuite la manière dont le
premier instant ça a été a été instruit
la chambre d'instruction
apparemment il ya un refus d'accepter
les la reconstitution des événements
il ya eu aussi quand même un délai très
important pour lequel il n'y a pas eu de
reconnaissance de l'action de ces mythes
on peut y avoir à la fois dafoe lit et a
même temps les intentions de cette folie
et pouvait être antisémite c'est
finalement la conclusion à laquelle est
arrivée la chambre d'instruction
et puis enfin si on a l'impression de
trop ou que trop peu
c'est à dire que ce soit et ça c'est un
peu le problème va tellement de ce
jugement mais de la loi dite dati qui
fait qu'il ya quand même une sorte de
procès dans le cas où les personnes sont
déclarées par par les experts
psychiatres c'est le cas de monsieur
traoré sont déclarées irresponsables on
organise néanmoins une procédure qui
n'est pas un pro c'est d'ailleurs une
chambre d'instruction et il y a
reconnaissance pour les victimes et une
décision qui est prise sur
l'irresponsabilité de l'autre oeuvre est
en fait finalement ça ça enfin ça crée
un sentiment d'attenté que la justice
soit soit mener jusqu'à son terme
notamment on aurait pu imaginer que le
procès en assises ait lieu et qu'il
conclut tout de même à
l'irresponsabilité monsieur traoré et au
moins il y aurait pas eu cette
impression de déni de justice
avant que cette loi là tu y existe
finalement on disait aux gens mais était
finalement il aura pas de procès parce
que l'auteur est complètement
irresponsable contre juge pas les trous
ce qui peut s'entendre mais à partir du
moment où on enclenche un dispositif de
ce type
le président la république est intervenu
à plusieurs reprises dyer et a laissé à
la con c'est à laisser accroire qu'ils
allaient y avoir un jugement est
finalement voilà on retire le tapis sous
les pieds
alors je pense que ça s'est extrêmement
on va penser qu'elle se débat en tout
cas beaucoup de réactions politiques
depuis sa décision judiciaire fonds
propose parmi elles de commenter celle
de marine le pen présidente du
rassemblement national
cette décision révoltante dans la sphère
sarah halimi assassiné dans des
conditions et pour des motifs antisémite
épouvantable créé un précédent très
inquiétant edouard de lamaze révoltant
et surtout créer un précédent comme
l'écrit marine le pen c'est votre avis
également il faut d'abord voir devient
beaucoup moins ça prend quelqu'un qui ne
croit n'a pas beaucoup de leçons à nous
donner sur la démocratie
je crois tout d'abord que par en tant
qu'avocat mais également cuillère de
justice il ya quand même de ne pas
enchaîner par un angle inédit situation
a bien un m
l'arrêt de la production en soi n'est
pas contestable au regard de la loi tout
le monde l'a dit des gros jury selon dit
et nous critiquent également la
colocation du stand par open uniquement
andrew donc cet arrêt de cassation pour
la 7 octobre il est avec nous dans notre
propre droit droit d'élire son nom loi
était à ceux qui
peut-être se poser des questions des
juges de paix sio parce que la situation
des vêtements spéciaux versante et je
crois que c'est plutôt l'origine de la
sic pour analyser et par la cour des
comptes à des louches qui trop tard le
benno macron la vie humaine ou car
tellement modifié dalo surin est
nécessaire dans une situation de
polémiques comme celle là où les propos
de marine le pen bamboo paraît pas de
nature de pouvoir et sereine et morales
l'a fait et puis est vraiment gêné
devenir une victime et d'un des grands
types racine sy et la création d'un ami
principe de ce crime je crois qu'il faut
il ya deux principes et la la c'est
l'analyse la peine est à dire la perte
dalida le pen l'appel doit pas être
aveugle et doivent être regardées
attaque mais d'été aujourd'hui on était
petit mais où tiendra devrait toujours
dans tous les procès oui oui le yari un
petit problème de ce soir je vous
propose edouard de lamaze de reprendre
la parole dans quelques instants edouard
de lamaze qui nous disaient voilà c'est
la loi c'est vrai qu'il ya du le droit
on applique le droit les jeux/jouets
appliquer le droit
gérald darmanin nous dit le président de
la république et le garde des sceaux ont
dit qu'il fallait changer la loi les
juges appliquent la loi
elle est sûrement le mal fait alors
c'est vrai que le moins qu'on puisse
dire devant la sauvagerie de ce crime
on se dit en gros guillaume bigot si on
a des envies de meurtre voilà ma foi il
suffit de fumer un petit peu voilà deux
jours avant pour parler familièrement et
on n'est pas responsable
c'est ça que ça veut dire parce que
c'est vrai que non mais là je prend un
raccourci mais pardonnez moi c'est un
petit peu l'impression que ça donne de
l'extérieur 1
guillaume bigot par exemple exactement
ont fait le problème c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de confusion dans cette dans
cette affaire il ya confusion entre la
notion disons de d'abolition du
discernement est altération du
discernement ou à l'abolition du
discernement
si on prenait d'alcool et que vous
faites un accident de la route c'est une
circonstance aggravante pas du tout les
circonstances atténuantes votre
discernement a été a été altérée en pâte
si vous êtes déclaré candidat avant
dément alors c'est plus le terme qui est
utilisé aujourd'hui il est fou vous êtes
irresponsable pénalement donc à une
altération total discernement donc un
mélange des deux et à la question de
savoir où était le cursus est ce que
finalement il était raide dingue en fait
ils sont 200 son discernement était
totalement abolis ou simplement altéré
ensuite la deuxième question c'est la
question de la part de la folie la part
des stupéfiants et là aussi c'est assez
complexe parce que finalement
apparemment sur les 6,4 on dit c'est
qu'il était fou et que les stupéfiants
en créant accélérer le processus
mais donc ce que vous que votre question
est très bonne parce qu'on a on a laissé
dans l'opinion publique s'installer la
réalité dans cette affaire qui été
amenés à manali de manière calamiteuse
temps par le politique par la police
hier que finalement c'était la prise de
cannabis qui avait conduit à cette
assène à ce crime et qu'ensuite c'est
parce que comme il avait pris du
cannabis finalement la justice avait
considéré qu' il n'était pas responsable
non pas être la justice elle s'est
appuyée sur l'expertisé psychiatrique et
ça c'est vrai et c'est tout à fait
conforme à la loi et elle a jugé que son
état de santé mentale était telle qu'ils
n'étaient plus du tout responsable donc
on ne pouvait pas le juger c'est ça le
fond de la faire donc ça a laissé
et puis et puis l'on pourrait attendre
mon sens parler d'une sorte de
présomption disons de laxisme judiciaire
et en particulier à l'égard des crimes
commis par les immigrés à qui on a
trouvé et notamment les immigrés
musulmans à ne pas parler de l'islamiste
qui a fait l'objet d'un déni pendant des
décennies en particulier de l'islamisme
qui visait
la communauté juive en france et de
l'antisémitisme islamistes donc là il ya
une sorte de fée de présomption de
laxisme de la part de l'opinion publique
à l'égard de justice on pourrait dire
pour résumer que c'est tout à fait
l'honneur de la justice de résister à la
pression de l'opinion publique et de ne
pas juger un fou ça c'est tout à fait
vrai on connaît d'année mois ont baissé
de distribuer la parole pardonnez moi
justement cette suspicion est ce qu'il
s'agit simplement d'une décision justice
voilà la loi est appliquée où il ya un
peu d'idéologie alors évidemment vous
allez pas me répondre à cette question
mais elle a le mérite d'être posée parce
que il ya ce soupçon là aujourd'hui
forcément puisque au final ça a mis du
temps mais le caractère antisémite a été
retenue mais n'est ce n'est pas traduit
en justice dont il ya un côté absurde
entre ces deux théories ces deux tests
jeu laissez moi croire que n'y a pas un
des magistrats de la cour de cassation
qu'il pleuvait à boire mais eu des idées
aussi criminel ou même une absence de
reconnaissance de cette ce caractère
horrible de la cité certainement pas ils
ont métier qu'ils avaient à effectuer
mais la mission était la leur et vous
pigez regarde la situation de droits ils
étaient offerts dans ce qui est un peu
la mazda6 que jamais ces coupes a
commencé où les responsabilités retenu
mon peuvent satisfaire à la réparation
civile ou même une association qui se
porteraient hop et lui dit c'est ce
n'est pas on n'est pas vous avez d'un
côté une décision du site droit qui est
insatisfaisant n'est d'accord mais tu es
partie régulière il a le côté vous avez
des reparti départ des minimes et des
parties civiles qui a vu le titre engagé
d'action en israël on gare de l'entendre
on a peur de madame halimi et qui va
demander réparation
les lya deux fondamentaux dans la
justice entre la partie civile et la
représentation devant
l'intérêt général et dossier il est
parti pour vingt ans non non on est
parti pour vingt ans en hôpital
psychiatrique
c'est la seule qui était qui a organisé
des défauts dans l'état s'est pas pour
autant les parties civiles ont été
réparés leur préjudice et qui ne valent
pas effectivement faire le procès
d'antisémitisme au regard de cet appel
voyez y pelé de répondants peuvent vivre
ensemble il faut le faire vivre ensemble
et pas l'un contre l'autre
comment bien l'entendre pour marine le
pen je te propose avant de vous faire
réagir
écoutez la réaction de julien bayou
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts qui est plus modérée on va
dire que celle qu'on a pu entendre au
rassemblement national ou même chez les
républicains à écouter julien bayou je
comprends l'émoi de la communauté juive
mais on doit conserver ce principe on ne
juge pas les fous la justice ce n'est
pas la vengeance
alors guillaume bigot il ya plusieurs
choses qui attire l'attention c'est vrai
que julien bayou qui semble résumer cet
émoi la communauté juive c'est assez
étonnant vous avez le sentiment qu'avec
les juifs qui ont été choqués dans cette
affaire aujourd'hui en france non non du
terrain ce serait totalement totalement
inacceptable donc je répète on fait ça
qu'il peut être difficile à comprendre
tout acte antisémite entrons ce n'est
pas que la terre n'a été vu que c'est la
terre de la communauté nationale
comme tout islamophobe d'ailleurs non
skis et ski
ce qui est difficile à comprendre c'est
qu'il ya une irresponsabilité sans doute
de l'auteur son book ainsi qu'à moi même
mais et que simultanément cette se fout
finalement n'a pas dit on diriger sa
folie le par hasard il a dirigé par ce
qu'il a été nourrie par un antisémitisme
islamique qui se diffuse est très large
mais malheureusement diffusé dans
d'autres pays et que ça apprécié ce
qu'on attend quelque sorte
il ya une folie si vous voulez dans un
autre cas dans un autre car nous y voilà
ce type était était dingue
donc on ne peut pas le juger fallait
d'un ça c'est très simple à comprendre
mais là il ya eu la pollution par le
cadet
dix sept cannabis qui a déclenché sa
bombe et non il était fou et
deuxièmement il ya la question dans le
säntis et je pense que soit il ne
fallait pas du tout mettre le doigt dans
un dans une tente dans un des quelque
sorte un nom un engrenage judiciaire
mais la loi d'être il obligeait
finalement et donc ça a créé une attente
de procès et puis à une sorte de coït
interrompu a dépassé en effet plus de
français allait rentrer chez nous
puisqu'il est irresponsable et monsieur
a tout à fait raison c'est conforme à la
loi mais c'est complètement absurde en
fait donc soit il était d'un an le juger
par isa l'opinion aurait pu comprendre
soit il fallait le renvoyer dans la cour
d'assises évidemment et là on aurait pu
avoir le procès peut-être cannabis mais
surtout le procès plus grave un
véritable procès si vous voulez
peut-être on aurait pu le déclarer à la
fois irresponsable lui est considéré
qu'il y avait là m kylie à un ancien
litis mme denat turkistani qui se
propage dans le pays et qui est très
grave et qu'il aurait qui est je pense
que dans un procès il est moins juge un
homme on juge un fait on juge les faits
il ya toujours un retentissement
politique sociale à un procès c'est
normal il faut l'accepter d'ailleurs est
donc là vraiment on a l'impression que
la magistrature
le monde judiciaire s'est recroquevillé
sur lui même a voulu appliquer de
manière extrêmement tatillonne les
textes sans comprendre la portée
politique de cette affaire
et maintenant la portée politique est
encore plus grave parce que là il n'y
aura probablement c'est la loi
israélienne possibilité d'enclencher un
procès mais comme la france n'extrade
pas ses nationaux alors votre toit la
situation de protéger ce type est un
triste sire en épouvantail le personnage
même s'il est fou en tout cas il est
manifestement en plus d'être fou
islamistes et antisémites au dernier
degré et donc on va le protéger enfin
goyer que ça fait monter le
communautarisme et ça crée une situation
qui est vraiment très très délétère
mètres de la base le mot de la fin pour
vous la justice n'a pas pris la mesure
de justement de son retentissement
politique et emmanuel
maintenant avec raison d'une certaine
manière de siffler si je puis dire la
fin de la récréation
en tout cas demandé que la loi change
voilà je crois que la justice a
parfaitement compris ce qu'elle faisait
elle a parfaitement pris conscience et
je connais pour konaté juge quand même
de ces hauts magistrats de notre france
et qui n'ont rien d'antisémite soyons de
la semaine et on le voit à travers tout
pour décision
on paie conscience du peu de couloir
qu'ils avaient de la nécessité
d'analyser le droit au regard de cette
rapport d' expertise dont un seul les
scènes à un doute sur la capacité de
l'aliénation de l'acte donc vous voyez
on est dans une situation kafkaïenne et
ne faisons pas d'amalgamé moi je crois
que ce qui est fondamental c'est de
continuer à garder la personnalisation
de la peine l'individuation de la peine
chaque personne à droite étaient jugés
en fonction de sa personnalité
si cette personnalité est insupportable
comme elle l'est et monsieur à raison
comme elle l'est pour la nation toute
entière au nom de l'antisémitisme eh
bien il ya d'autres tribunaux qui vont
pouvoir le juger et de déclarer mais pas
lorsqu'on étudie la la peine en tant que
tel un regard d'un texte de loi voté au
nom du peuple français
changeons le texte les magistrats
rendront une autre décision fut conforme
peut-être à l'émotion justifié
d'aujourd'hui peut-être à la règle la
morale et de l'éthique nationale
mais la situation allait comme celle là
elle n'est pas elle est pas
satisfaisante mais n'est pas authentique
a comme elle les fait actuel merci
edouard de lamaze guillaume bigot
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france